I don't think
Austin Butler celebrates his big Golden
Globes win with a kiss from girlfriend
Kaia Gerber
must be my bestest girl the actor took
home his first ever Golden Globe on
Tuesday for his portrayal of Elvis
Presley in the 2022 biopic Elvis
oh man all my words are leaving me
um I I just am so grateful right now I'm
in this room full of my heroes I cannot
believe I'm here right now
look right in my face
to my fellow nominees you have turned in
the most beautiful profound work and I
am so honored and proud to be listed
among you Austin beat out Brendan
Frazier Hugh Jackman Bill Nye and Jeremy
Pope in the best actor Motion Picture
drama category it just like this cherry
on top when the
did A Moment Like This that feels like
something I've seen a lot of my heroes
get up there and do you know it's it's
really special I Austin brought his
sister Ashley as his plus one to the big
night how proud are you of this kid
right here I am so amazingly proud I can
hardly even express it in words but
after his big win Austin was spotted
getting a big old celebratory smooch
from his girlfriend Kaia Gerber what we
gonna do tonight what's the night guys I
don't know what are we gonna do I'm
rolling with the punches right now I I'm
sure I'll have a good time tonight yes
and that's exactly what they did hitting
up a Golden Globes after party it's
really special they had so much fun that
Austin Kaya and Ashley were snapped
leaving The Bash at 3 30 in the morning
that's Kaya resting her head on Austin's
shoulder in the back of the car between
the family time taking home Globes gold
and celebrating with his Leading Lady
seems Austin was All Shook Up in the
best way I just feel so grateful right
now I am
I uh I'm still coming back from sort of
blacking out thank you thank you
[Music]